avec nous charles et mon pdg de la
caisse de dépôt monsieur mambé soir
bonsoir
une déclaration surprenante que vous
avez fait vous avez laissé entendre que
la caisse aurait été assez solide pour
encaisser les contrecoups d'une crise de
l'ampleur de celle de 2008 par dessus la
pandémie ça va si bien que ça à la
caisse de dépôt mais je pense qu une
solidité financière qui est là la caisse
une gestion des risques qui parmi les
plus sophistiqués au monde pour une
gestion prudente tant au niveau de notre
levier de notre position et je pense que
dans ce contexte là dans une situation
comme on a vécu c'est payant passe
complètement leur redéployer voir des
opportunités bien en profiter est ce que
on doit quand même comprendre d'une
telle résilience qu'on pourrait se
diriger même vers des rendements
positifs pour la deuxième moitié de
l'année mais écoutez on tout peut se
passer jusqu'à la fin de l'année nous
avons maintenant un environnement ces
volatiles un marché hors norme mais ce
que je dirai ce que il reste des
endroits où ça demeure un défi est
encore d aéroport qui sont fermés les
centres d'achat est un peu plus
difficile et certains secteurs comme
vous avez dit ou est-ce que la reprise
est inégale mais j'aime bien ce que je
vois depuis le 31 mars et puis le rebond
je crois que dans l'ensemble la
direction tout ça s'est amélioré
vous parliez de centres commerciaux
entre autres bon il ya de grandes pertes
concernant vos actifs dans l'immobilier
perte de 15 à 20% entre autres
notamment les centres commerciaux vous
comptez réduire et transformer ses
actifs la wii puis je pense que c'est
quelque chose dont on avait déjà un plan
en marche et crise la nécessité de
l'accélérer on est déjà très actif on a
déjà fait certaines transactions mais
c'est une combinaison un peu de
plusieurs mesures chaque centre d'achats
prévoir une solution qui lui adapté dans
certains cas ce sera un plan de
redéploiement
on verra peut-être plusieurs catégories
du mobilier le résidentiel ce qu'on
venait avec le bureau la logistique dans
certains cas alors il s'agit d'être rude
1 d'avancé d'être actif mais ne pas non
plus en même temps faire une vente de
feu je pense dans le contexte actuel on
a le luxe d'être patient tout un tas
très très très actif dans ce qu'on a
identifié comme initiative interactifs
dans certains secteurs entre autres vous
avez insisté aujourd'hui sur
l'importance de donner de l'élan à des
jeunes pousses dans des secteurs
innovants et on pense à élémentaire hier
la vente de l'entreprise qu'on
considérait comme un fleuron de
l'intelligence artificielle au québec
vous avez laissé entendre que c'était
une bonne chose que c'était une façon
d'appuyer la croissance de cette
entreprise là est ce qui est pas là une
contradiction dessus et m'ont vous savez
madame saint-arnoult l'économie cpo
statique un il ya des gangs il ya des
perdants
et puis pour un élément tm et on a dit
aux autres sociétés qui sont des jeunes
pousses des litespeed des nouveaux
véhicules dans le domaine technologique
fleurissent et deviennent des champions
mondiaux
maintenant dans le cas de l'emmental
c'est très important pour une
intelligence artificielle on le fait
avec
l'annnonce de l'acquisition d'un tact au
royaume uni on a réussi à avoir des
engagements québec où le centre
d'intelligence artificielle mondiale
d'un tacle va être montréal des
centaines d'emplois dans ce secteur doit
pour élémentaire on les a appuyés
quotidiennement c'est un dossier très
intense
on a travaillé avec mécanisée ont leur
ouvert des portes
mais en bout de ligne ce modèle
d'affaires l'anneau peut-être au christ
on sens commercial de la façon qu'on
leur ait espérer mais en même temps on a
trouvé un bon opérateurs qui vont ouvrir
des portes que les emprunts intelligence
artificielle reste au québec dans les
circonstances était la meilleure
solution
vous avez évoqué d'autres joueurs du
secteur litespeed nous
et quel rôle la caisse peut-être joué
pour appuyer la croissance de ces
entreprises là m'est arrivé à ce qu'on
les garde lorsqu'elles seront devenus de
grandes entreprises qui attireront
l'envi de la silicon valley par exemple
mais vous avez raison c'est nouvelle
société la leur valeur il ya des actifs
intangibles la propriété intellectuelle
on commence au départ à investir à
travers des fonds qui lorsqu'elles sont
au petit on les identifie on investit à
travers ces fonds là quand elles
grandissent c'est là qu'on arrive avec
les investissements encore plus
important on les accompagne à croître
rapidement par acquisitions sur la scène
mondiale
vous avez raison c'est à ce moment là
dedans cri dès le départ avec nos droits
de gouvernance une présence au conseil
en accompagnement de les suivre par la
suite puis je pense qu'avec ces sociétés
là et on crée vraiment le nouveau québec
king qui émergent
bon il ya ce dossier avec garde à
monsieur aimons le pdg de garda qui vous
accuse de lui mettre des bâtons dans les
roues dans ses projets pour faire
l'acquisition de géants de la sécurité
une entreprise g4s vous lui avez répondu
par une mise en demeure vous en ai tout
dans ce dossier mais on a pas mal tout
dit le tue madame st-arnaud ce que je
dirais c'est que en premier lieu nous
avons dès le départ appuyé garda quand
il avait des discussions privées avec
g4s est le souhait le désir de prioriser
l'entreprise pour devenir réaliser son
rêve devenir le champion mondial dans la
sécurité
ce que je dirais maintenant une fois que
l'entreprise de c'est de ne pas prendre
notre of la caisse a agi avec intégrité
et là dedans et de cette façon là je
veux rassurer tout le monde
mettre des bâtons dans les roues c'est
parce qu'on fait on appuie les
entreprises du québec
bon vous et on va passer au dossier du
rem il ya eu des retards supplémentaires
plusieurs embûches lié à bron en partie
à la pandémie
le fédéral qui annonce est possiblement
un financement pour la station de
l'aéroport montréal trudeau ce n'a pas
été facile ce dossier là
et pourtant vous laissez entendre que le
rendement va rester dans la fourchette
prévue
vous savez je crois que au niveau de ce
projet là dans l'ensemble oui on est
confiant on réitère qu on va être dans
la fourchette de rendement savez quand
on se lance dans ce projet là on essaie
d'être conservateur dans nos estimés on
a des solutions pour ce qu'on a à faire
évidemment il ya un coût qui vient avec
ça je le reconnais mais dans les
circonstances d'un projet qui encore sa
raison d'être puis qui va aller au coeur
de la rentabilité qu'on a premier à
l'origine dans ce projet là bon monsieur
est bon il reste quelques mois pour la
fin de l'exercice c'est un contexte
toujours pas évident on parle de
ralentissement économique pour les
prochains mois quelles sont vos
priorités pour assurer la résilience la
caisse et on continue toujours je
voudrais à exécuter notre stratégie
alors une stratégie qui s'orientent vers
au niveau du crédit la dette privée au
niveau des placements privés ce qui est
vraiment réussie c'est d'être dans les
bons secteurs là fintec l'assurance la
santé et la technologie au niveau de
l'infrastructure en est un des plus
grands investisseurs au monde dans un
contexte de relance des gouvernements
il ya énormément à faire dans les
renouvelables alors je pense qu'avec ces
initiatives leçon continue à s'inscrire
dans nos actions on va arriver à avoir
des bons rendements je reprendrai saison
on souhaite tous merci beaucoup monsieur
si on voit